October 4th 2017 time 8 30 a.m location
the border between Niger and Mali in
West Africa in the West African country
of Niger a small team of American
special forces and Nigerian soldiers are
returning from a low risk Mission near
the border of Mali after two days in the
field the soldiers are tired hungry and
need to rest so they choose the nearby
Village of Tango Tango as a stop 10 30
a.m local time their Convoy of both
armored and regular Vehicles arrive in
Tango Tango the Americans give the
soldiers half an hour to eat and rest
while they meet up with Village leaders
the meeting makes the American and
Nigerian team leaders nervous not
willing to leave their vehicles
unattended the American split up with
some of them staying back to stand guard
and that's where things started to go
wrong instead of the half hour like they
planned the village Elders drive it on
for more than an hour during that time
the American soldiers watching the cars
spot two motorcycles racing out of the
village into the fields something is
definitely not right but with no other
choice they sit tight hoping they can
leave before disaster strike both the
American and Nigerian surges aren't
equipped well enough to fight off an
ambush if it happened and they know it
at 11 35 am the meeting ends and the a
car Convoy leads the village back to the
base but on the way back that is when it
happens
approximately 100 meters outside of the
village enemy forces attacked the team
with small arms fire directed at the
rear of the Convoy
enemy fire was initially light then
intensified as they Advanced through the
woods on the team's position is the next
state militias had launched an ambush
and the American and Nigerian soldiers
were outnumbered out armed and taking
heavy losses what's worse is that none
of the eight American soldiers in that
Convoy had any previous combat
experience none of them had even trained
together before they left the mission it
was a complete disaster the Amish would
go on for more than an hour and by the
time they managed to escape four
Americans and four Nigerians were dead
it was one of the worst combat losses
American forces overseas had taken in a
long time but they weren't the first
casualties either we had them in Somalia
and Kenya we had them in Tunisia we had
them in Mali we had them in Niger
Nigeria Cameroon Chad but those were
kept as quiet as possible nobody talked
about it said the ex-commander of
Special Operations come in Africa see in
2017 American troops carried out an
average of 10 missions a day in Africa
all in secrets that's more missions than
he did in the entire Middle East many of
them were carried out by American
soldiers and Armed Forces few of them
were ever made public and even fewer had
the right approval see over the past few
years America has been waging a secret
war in Africa a war that doesn't need
Congressional approval without checks
and balances a word that you've never
heard about on TV and it's bigger than
anything you could have ever imagined
stay dangerous in this is America's
Secret war in Africa
[Music]
despite these Secret Wars Africa's
economy is actually booming right now
with a ton of smart people over there
and if you are in a business where you
have to ship stuff then spending the
next 60 seconds to learn about our
sponsorship station is gonna save you a
ton of money shipstation makes shipping
stuff easier than ever by letting you
automate most of your manual work while
also hooking you up with the best
shipping rates out there with up to 84
off from Top carers like UPS USPS and
DHL Express there's a reason why huge
Brands like Joe Rogan's on it uses them
with shipstation you don't need to
manually track pending orders or go to a
dozen shipping websites to find and
print affordable labels you can import
orders automatically from whatever
platform you're selling on compare
shipping rates right on shipstation and
then print custom branded discounted
shipping labels all in one place and the
best part is that shipstation takes less
than five minutes to set up you start by
creating an account then you connect to
whatever selling platform you use
Shopify Amazon Etsy eBay in fact most
marketplaces and stores are supported
and finally you just connect your
shipping carrier accounts and that is it
you are ready to start getting all the
benefits of ship station including
instant tracking updates for your
customers and a carrier rate comparison
tool so start saving money on shipping
right now by going to shipstation.com to
get a free 60-day trial that's
shipstation.com for a free 60-day trial
with the link below thanks to
shipstation for sponsoring this video
the four American soldiers that died in
Niger in 2017 were never supposed to be
in active combat they were only there to
offer backup for the main American
special ops team that was on their way
VIA helicopter but the weather wasn't
good so instead the helicopters turned
back leaving the ground team out in the
cold the original team was an American
Black Ops unit that's what hunting down
a man they said was a team of leader in
the region and unlike the teen that was
attacked this means spec ops team had
plenty of combat experience and they
were deployed to Niger under something
called the 127e authority and if you
don't know what that means that is
exactly the points session 127e is a
secret Authority that allows American
soldiers to be deployed and go on
missions without any need for the public
or Congress to know anything about what
they're doing basically it allows highly
trained American soldiers to be sent to
countries like Niger Somalia Cameroon to
train assistant even command local units
of soldiers to hunt down Tunes or at
least that's the official description
it's less for helping you and more
you're doing our bidding said one act of
doing Green Beret officer with recent
experience in West Africa instead of
just hunting down terrorists most of the
127e programs involve Americans using
local soldiers as proxies to fight
America's Wars and battles for them
according to Central Command these
programs have led to the capture and
death of thousands of terms but the fine
details of how many were killed or how
they were killed is being kept a closely
guarded Secrets officially these
American soldiers are not supposed to be
in active combat instead they're only
there to help local soldiers do the
fighting for them but if that's the case
what were these two teams of American
Special Forces soldiers doing on the
ground in action in Niger and that is
where the mystery comes in since these
programs don't officially allow American
soldiers to take part in combat these
programs do not need the same oversight
or approvals that other operations do
which means Congress the American public
and even the African countries they're
in have zero idea about what they're up
to and if we've learned anything from
Iraq sending American soldiers into
third world countries without any
supervision never ends well
foreign
[Applause]
in each of these African countries you
have the American Special Forces
soldiers that are there to train and
advise under Section 127e and then you
have the local African soldiers that are
there to do what the Americans tell them
and in Cameroon these local soldiers go
by the name of the rapid intervention
Battalion or bir in French in Cameroon
the Americans and their proxies were
supposed to hunt down but the
cameroonian government also had its own
problems the government was fighting
local militias who wanted to declare
independence from Cameroon this fight
had nothing to do with America nothing
to do with and nothing to do with the
American soldiers in Cameroon but on the
ground things aren't that simple because
as it turns out these bir soldiers who
are trained advice and equipped by the
Americans aren't just using their
Newfound skills and weapons against them
instead they're using their new American
equipment and training to commit serious
war crimes against the rebels according
to American officials the bir members
are hand selected partner forces we
train them and we equip them and they
specifically go after high value
counter-terrorism targets but these
American officials convey really leave
out the fact that their hand-picked
cameroonian soldiers are also women
looting and burning homes killing
three-year-old children and executing
innocent civilians they kill randomly
they arrest randomly they arrest
children they open fire on the civilian
population but obviously that has
nothing to do with the Americans we only
train them and give them guns and pay
them money but we definitely don't
support their human resid uses that's
not on us and that is not where it ends
because all these human rights abuses
the Bri commits using their American
training and American weapons well it's
a great way to make even more people in
Cameroon hate America which is only
going to inspire even more violent
extremism although the 127e program
doesn't allow Americans to enter combat
and participate in any of these abuses
thanks to the secrecy around 127e
programs we would never truly know
whether American soldiers and Cameroon
knew about or participated in war crimes
committed by the bir but that doesn't
really matter after these abuses became
public the head of the U.S Africa
command announced that they'd be
slashing funny for the bir and the the
127e program in Cameroon but that was
all a lie too because while everyone was
busy praising America for standing up
against human rights abuses the Pentagon
was still employing bir soldiers for
months after the reports became public
for more than 15 years after American
soldiers weren't punished for the human
rights abuses in Iraq the American
government got away with supporting
similar abuses in Cameroon but thanks to
the 127e program no one not even
Congress will ever know just how
involved the Americans were and what
happened in Cameroon and that is not
where the story ends
foreign
[Music]
knows about America's war in Afghanistan
it went up for 20 years everyone knows
how terrible and pointless it was but
what about Somalia see thanks to 127e
programs Somalia has also been the
target of hundreds of American missions
since 2001. the same year we invaded
Afghanistan but no one ever mentioned
Somalia in the news instead of American
government officials can come out and
just straight up lie to the public like
what the former White House Press
Secretary said in 2021 there are other
parts of the world Somalia Libya Yemen
where we don't have a presence on the
ground she said when in reality that
cannot be further from the truth Somalia
was one of the first countries to have
American soldiers deployed under section
127e at first the government said it
needed soldiers and Somalia to fight
then it was to fight Pirates and then
for a while they were just there finding
with no clear legal basis to even be in
Somalia for more than 20 years 127 e
programs have allowed American soldiers
and Somalia to do almost whatever they
want but unlike the war in Afghanistan
no one is watching them in Somalia no
one is tracking their spending or
confirming their kills and since then
127e programs have spread to Niger
Cameroon Libya Kenya Tunisia Mali
Nigeria Mauritania and more why they say
it's the fighter which is true and part
of the story but these Secret Wars are
also a great way to control Africa
[Music]
by deploying American soldiers into
African countries America gets to
influence their governments America gets
to have the local troops do the dirty
work for them and America gets to wage
war without anyone telling them no
dangerous terrorists to take out sent in
the local soldiers to get massacred
instead of us human rights abuses to
commit the Locos did it we would never
versus torture I mean interrogate they
did it not us what the 127e the Pentagon
gets to decide who wins Civil Wars and
who doesn't who gets AIDS and guns and
who doesn't and of course all of this is
also very profitable for American
defense contractors for years the Middle
East kept the fence contractors busy but
those Wars came with far too much red
tape too many people were asking for
receipts complaining about spending
luckily barely anyone knows about
America's wars in Africa so the
government can keep running these
forever Wars far away from the public
eye
but you want to know what's even worse
than America's Secret wars in Africa
America's Secret war in Yemen see while
everyone complains about Putin's abuses
in Ukraine which are very bad America
has also been participating in some
terrible abuses and a little-known
country called Yemen see since the war
in Yemen started America has
participated in the deaths of more than
377 000 yemeni people sixty percent of
them die from starvation drinking unsafe
water or from not being able to get
medical care and at least 10 000
children have died as a result of the
fighting many call this the worst
humanitarian crisis happening on Earth
right now and yet I bet that you have
never heard about any of this why
because America's Secret war in Yemen is
not about terrorism it's not about wmds
it's not even about a dictator America
wants to get rid of no America's
Devastation of the poorest country in
the Middle East is for one thing and one
thing only to keep their Pals in the
Saudi royal family happy and we expose
it all in our new private documentary
that you can watch right now by clicking
the card on the screen videos on war
like this commonly get them monetized
but thankfully that's why we have this
YouTube membership where we post a new
private documentary not available
anywhere else once a month so click the
card on the screen to watch now
[Music]